I think the war against
drugs is lost, so we currently have
a black market because the state
can't define cannabis addiction right now. It doesn't
produce
such colorful, sad pictures of
someone sleeping under the bridge or
something. It's just not
comprehensible when you look at
which ones  driven straight alcohol
should be
a political sessions and topix
shaping the election of
[music]
germany legalize cannabis
and i think cannabis is
basically legalized today my
name is martin rödiger and i am very skeptical when it comes to the topic of
legalizing cannabis from practice from
the  I'm
highly skeptical about this simply
because we already have a lot of drugs on the
street and I don't think we
can estimate how massive the
effects will be if we
release more substances
it's always pretended to
stay that way  any new substances so
j  a release but they are not
already on the street and off the street
like i get them away so it's
about bringing samples under control either
through legalization it was
for today have this black market that
takes place on the street for the
street conditions that  is of course the
wrong way to deal with these substances
, which one way or another because
they are consumed one way or another yes
i understand the point and i think
maybe my formulation from the street was
n't the correct one i'm
pretty sure when it comes to
legalization  that will simplify the
access conditions and if
we have simple access conditions
we will simply have more users in the end and
more users means more dependents and more
dependents means more people looking for work that
’s personal for me right now
i would say it’s calcio no harm but
that means more  sorry and that means more
problems
[music]
[music
] legalization means  just
not that the access is made easier
, i mean the access is
super easy right now in berlin
if you look at the infrastructure even
in the most remote regions of
germany, so
drugs are there because they are available
it couldn't be easier right now
[Music]
that's why I
don't want to expand the access, but
bring the content in a controlled way so that
once there the attraction of the forbidden
is lost and the thing then
belongs there, so it's where it belongs
in a specialist shop that also has the
appropriate advice is where  the
quality is also right i mean what
percentage of the drug problems we
already have go back to the
fact that the stuff is on the street
that it's dirty that it's covered with up to 2
dust that the
active substance content is completely
uncontrollable so that's it  yes, the nice thing about it
as soon as you take control of the city again
, he has an egg  n whole
smorgasbord of possibilities to regulate things
we have age limits
we have the question of to what extent
certain educational measures have
to be carried out accordingly I
want to have my driver’s license that
also makes you at least right course first
aid more can be anything you
want but please you  basic
information that also helps,
unfortunately, it can still be communicated openly at all
, that everyone, the
le council, that parents, that people do the
prevention work, that the police officer was
simply able to talk openly about
what fiber is without the
sword of Damocles of illegality always hanging
over you  this is what makes this course possible for the first time
ever and that i think
is the most important thing and to
connect drug problems so as far as legality goes,
i'm there with
you, so criminalization is a
topic that drives us in addiction therapy
and
[  music]
[music]
because we see d  Most of the
people who are in prison because of drugs are in prison
because they are ill and they are
in prison from what
you see here in the numbers and also
what we are personally experiencing is not
the right place to solve this problem at the
same time me  I'm a bit
skeptical about the idea
we'll get it, so to speak, we'll make it
legal then get off the street and
then we'll regulate that I do
n't think it will work like that I
think I can well imagine that
it will
if it  there are meaningful and angelic
regulations, what about
access restrictions from the age of 21 or what
do I know, that would be some
details
that are imposed on the masses of the population,
then there will be the black market at the same
time because the black market is the
normal entry-level consumer, twelve
or 13 or something and they want it
still consume
right to start, maybe a
question for you just to
understanding to what extent do you think that cannabis is a gateway drug that's how it
is
in the specialist community it's a
long debate and there's a lot of data
that says yes it's a gateway drug there's a
lot of data that says it's not a
gateway drug that's a
bit there too  which side you end up
on so in my eyes there is
no clear empirical evidence
one way or the other from a vach point of view
it's a bit irrelevant because
the long term consequences of
addictive or abusive
cannabis use are so severe
it doesn't matter if it's sort of
another entry is another drug
world or not we treat
people who got
into party drugs and heroin or something like that via cannabis at some point,
who are seriously
ill and need help, as
well as people who stayed with
cannabis and who are seriously ill and  need help
yes or no the danger of
cannabis is underestimated
yes so that would  I definitely
say
and that's also something I see in my
daily work, of
course, we still have fewer
pure cannabis users in
therapy than there are
clients with with with with other
dependencies, but that's
less because of the low level
potential for damage
but that is often due to the fact that
from my point of view there is
a risk in which we know alcohol addiction has a similar risk as in
Vienna, which
is that it develops very very slowly
, so whoever starts consuming heroin now
becomes dependent relatively quickly and has relatively
quickly  there are corresponding consequences and there are
measurable problems
that you have to deal with somehow that's
not the case with cannabis, it takes a very
long time, just like with alcohol addiction
and once the first
addictions appear then you
've sometimes had 10, 20, 30 years of consumption behind you
himself and gets the problems that develop
from it  it doesn’t tickle at all
with the addiction and with the substances in
connection so if someone in their mid-
40s after 25 years of consumption
she sleeps worse and worse has
less and less desire for things
whatever then they often don’t think of it
if it’s been 20 years
or what  also always
said that
it could have something to do with it, that people then go
to a psychotherapist or people
do whatever to deal with it
and usually doesn’t realize that it’s
actually that they are dependent and
that the problems arise from that
and  that's that that's what what we
'll see again the
dangers of cannabis in particular five probably
one of the things that have been
best researched in the world there is
probably hardly a drug that has
researched all conceivable
risks and possible damage so
systematically by where the
Last decades then fell
drug research duty to understand only
this auft  rag had found dangers about
canada is because that was what was
politically wanted what was
financed there are certain dangers in it is
minors but even
conscription is always to say that a
large part of this whole data
is also collected or the area of
illegality where you  didn't know what
kind of dirt was in it and the total amount for
an adult human being
compared to many other risks that
we take in our lives is
negligible  or also
the gateway drug that then
somehow has to be a devil in it
somewhere in this cannabis it's
the same stuff that's currently being sold in
pharmacies motor is
definitely specialist information there
[music]
and if you look at what's in
there you have to be  ask what
can sometimes be attributed to
everything  which actually has nothing to do with
this substance itself
i have a question for both of you,
namely i sometimes have the feeling that
this criminalization of cannabis is
also a signal from the
consumers which then maybe contributes to people taking it
seriously
problems don't really dare to
get help because he's
somehow ashamed of consumption how does it look in
practice what insights conti meters
give so i would say
cannabis is actually something that you
really have to emphasize because it
's the
stigmatization now  At least in my
personal experience, it is
definitely bigger with other drugs, so I
think cannabis has a bit the
same problem as alcohol and
also and also and also tobacco that he
sees it differently in society, of course, in older society  from
but in our today someone who
now the last
few years any  I had no idea when I was young,
most of those who think about it today
tend to play it down,
so they draw the line when
someone is problematic or what is
problematic about consuming
their cannabis, so I have the
impression that you consume it quite stiffly
somehow in the
direction that the stigmatization
problem is
as 200,000 deaths every year in
germany from alcohol and
nicotine alone where the facc dangers are
clearly documented and not
disputed if but also third
effects for society are quite
dramatic, for example more
domestic violence  more
damage to property in the case of alcohol abuse
or consumption in general more violence as a
result of which cannabis does not usually
trigger i believe never there have neither
people died nor have
they become aggressive as a result they
sleep and dance so you
certainly know all these numbers
don't you think that that  arbitrary politics is  t
criminalizing one thing and
saying the other is just
personal responsibility but with
cannabis it's not that it's just
not understandable when you
look at the dangers alcohol
has in comparison to cannabis this
signal is sent out by this fruit
in logic  which simply no one
can explain properly so it is always
pretended as if a council
of wise men had just decided what has to be
legal now what isn't no that was
arbitrary that was racism that has
to do with a lot of things but not with
an objective standard  who
really applies the same parameters to all
substances yes or no
criminalization does more harm
than good
i think that is to some extent
the point
that is often forgotten in the argumentation
so drug policy as it is now
is nothing  what we
consider to be useful from a professional perspective, we
see exactly that the le  people we
treat and who often
come into conflict with the law because of their drug addiction
are that the team doesn’t
help that makes things worse and
that we are exactly the
opposite of how criminal that you would want to
change which decriminalization
that means but for  me not
conversely that legalization is the
right way what we see is that
usually there are often
people from illegal drugs who have
developed such a heavy
drug addiction over the years that
in many
cases they become criminals that it's
mostly about them  drug-related crime
it's about the len it's
about burglaries it's about fraud
it's also sometimes about bodily harm
whether it's more about the former
and that they ultimately end up in jail at some point
there is usually
more consumption then
they would be released again  immediately relapsed
delinquent whatever and so rotary
t the wheel moves on and on and in
the end you really could
n’t do anything at all and apart from
all the individual
suffering, it’s also simply a cost factor that is really
immense and precisely because the
cost factor is the money that
drug help has available at the moment  or what
prevention has available is
just a fraction of what is spent on
depression if
you look at how much police
prosecutors jail places what
money is invested we're talking about
billions we're talking about sums of this
the president would do the
prevention  and also the
drug help is only a dream and otherwise yes
i also agree very clearly
i personally am because he is currently on the
side that i would say that
legalizing it would certainly help in many
areas, also for example
the structures surrounding
dealing the  organized crime that
is also partly financed
by that  to get a grip on
the many arguments that he has already mentioned
health protection and so
on but what i find very exciting at the beginning
is that he was told
that the legalization
may also result in a higher number
of patients who become addicts,
for example  and i would just be
interested to know what
experiences there are from other countries and
are there mechanisms that you
might recommend if you want to take steps towards
legalization? there is
now, thank goodness, a lot of
experience. only the netherlands have been doing
this for decades  It has
n't started to rain and it's starting to rain
so that's saying yes you should take a look
at them because if you legalize
them you should do it right
so not every variant is right
there either but there are definitely experiences with that
and we should definitely do that
use accordingly so that one says
no stupid mistakes they make  others
may have already committed before us
[music]
i think it's a
misjudgment that with legalization we're giving up
the black market
the the black
market has to share the market of course we had to hand over papers
but it's going on to certain people
who viz  not
receive any advantage from the legalization he will continue to
sell to the people and of course he also brings
a lot of
expertise with you which may also be skimmed off the
legal market for the time being
and in the end you have to say that is
the tragic thing we experience as practitioners
cannabis addiction
doesn't produce such colourful, sad pictures of
someone sleeping under a bridge or
something like that, the drama of friends
of cannabis addiction is a
whole four quieter, much invisible
ones and that's why it doesn't end up on the big television cameras,
the question is that to me the  logic
reveals why legalization to more
of course i can set
the levy under
which conditions i hand it in but
i must not increase the state
control mechanisms for something legal
the state may
only intervene where it has control
rights if something is illegal or
prohibited a basic
control the citizens want them after all
probably not so currently we have a
black market because the state
can't determine which track is
sold there, he can't influence it
we don't know who's on it if
I know there's beer in each because there's beer in the bottle
I know there's beer in it now
he just got fluff in there or something like that it
was up to the state to have an influence he can
also have a formative influence then of
course we can also define rules where it
is allowed to consume everyone he
can do it too i
think i want to regulate the legal drugs more tightly and i
would like to regulate the illegal ones too
regulate and influence more  so
I would like the advertising ban as far as I was
doing something in Germany in the area of
tobacco advertising that's also got the
plan
I think the goal is that the
control that would come about of course
there is possibly a material
control that makes sense in some way
but that will
change  nothing to do with the fact that there will be a
parallel black one day who
will continue to do what he does and in
this respect it is also an addiction for me from a
medical point of view I simply see the
market growing
and more people will come yes or
no in Germany with me  the current
drug policy we have we throw
money out the window
so i can do that
yes the bad thing is not only that
we have a lot of money so if we
squander that all the money that
he is investing in repression that
would be quite  nice but we always have to
be aware of which law
we are talking about here we are talking about
tens of thousands of st  rafanzeige we're
talking about people here who just
because they decided to use cannabis
got their driver's license taken
away and thrown
out of school have criminal records who lose their apartment god
knows what kind of
stress they get
[music]
all this repression the  we here which
is operated so when
young people have first
contacts with the police is that they
get caught because of their joint the house is searched these are
harmful consequences there are many
sensible projects that are
financed and that are good
but natural and  I'm talking about it
clearly the majority of our
addiction-related damage does not come
from illegal drugs, about 1,000 people
die from illegal drugs every year and
, as you said, we have almost 200,000
deaths from our two legal drugs
that we consume, so I think
it is  is of course the is the
impact direction
is  t not good in your weighting but
nonetheless while the
trainer promoted meaningful projects within this direction
the war on drugs has
actually been claiming
tens of thousands of
deaths every year for many decades cannabis cocaine and many others if
you now say well the release will not be
the illegal market  finish immediately
clear that a process
that will take many years what would happen then the
solution to these many tens of thousands would
be to prevent the massive devastation that is being caused in many countries
i have to be
honest i think it's totally good
but also totally  bitter question so
i'm not a criminologist but i've been
dealing with the political
dimension for a long time and i have the impression
i think the war against
drugs is lost so i don't have the
impression that it doesn't matter if we have a
parallel legal market create the then
simply
e  will produce in competition between legal
entrants and illegal
entrants which will
just lead to my
opinion that there will be more
producers or whether we will
leave it like that i don't think
it makes a difference just looking at
the history of the variety  over
the millennia you mostly see that
addiction ultimately has something to do with prosperity the
more prosperity there is in the world
the more addiction there is son the
moment prosperity dwindles the addiction
dwindles so i think these are
ultimately the regulatory mechanisms
but i fear mine  small point of
view that that's the trick war against
drugs i don't think that it can be
won yes so to the thesis
that legalization wouldn't change anything because not everyone notices of
course you have to make
the offer attractive you ca
n't ask higher prices than
the black market  but just in Berlin
where I give my available  Since then,
if I have the opportunity to get a tested quality for the
same price at a lower price in a
specialist shop
, the vast
majority of consumers and most of them
are over 18 devils will continue
to serve the black market,
how are you two right?
intoxication those who have the right to intoxication
are obviously using those we have
already identified very
dangerous drugs legalized drugs
alcohol and nicotine but
obviously not with cannabis nor with other
drugs not right to
self-determination 1 1 basic law
article how do you feel about this that is a
very fundamental  unproblematic question
because
if someone develops a drug
addiction then if you lose it
if we
just want to express it biologically then a
certain part of the brain wins, namely the non-rational part of the brain that is
not more reasonable
in andy gradually gains the upper hand
in our thinking and acting  and people
often need years to sort of turn this process
around, which means it is actually
questionable whether someone who is addicted can make a
sensible decision regarding
his consumption, precisely
because the constitution is also addressed,
which means that the question
of the right to intoxication arises in the first place
not because the consumption of substances is
basically irrelevant at first
, but the question still arises as to whether these
massive state measures and a
total ban with punishable rules with
police deployments that the state must
first of all justify that
it speaks about yes or no
clarification  Addiction is still missing in the general
population,
so we have little open serious
discourse on the subject of drugs, on the subject of
drug maturity, on all the
cultural rules and I think
that's on has but I think that has the
greatest influence on
consumer behavior if simply a
society is openly clear  certain rules
def  ined what is appropriate that it is
inappropriate that we are much stronger than
any threat of punishment, especially with
young people, yes, we will totally
agree, so I think it comes
from us, too, so from a therapeutic point of
view, it will be about the
overall social and overall
drug dialogue, so that  which is
mainly run via illegal
drugs by a
majority of the population who
mainly consumes alcohol and nicotine
and that's
what we've produced in the overall mass the
majority of the
problems I would also find it much
cheaper
to look at it in a pub way yes
that doesn't have to be the case again  however,
topological saying be in it otherwise
the discussion wouldn't believe there
is something you would say that you can
forgive the other person totally well
and also something where he says that I would
then I don't say that at all with my
opposite yes I mean the in  In large
areas we are in complete agreement
that  The main question is what does
it look like when we approach the market
, but that the
criminalization of consumers and
Ford dependents is also the case in both
cases. We are in complete agreement,
so we have to look at it
and we certainly have to discuss it. That's why it's
yes  it is also important that you meet me
at some point so that
we can see what can we
try out what are the parameters that
may be important here that you
are aware of the advertising ban from the
outset then you have to be there right away
and then you have to see how the
dialogue can progress because
it just can't stay the way it is
i see it very similarly so
as far as the whole decriminalization debate is concerned
i'm completely pro and i think the
portuguese model has taken a
really great
a great pioneering role
[music]
and also dates  moderately you can see
that it works there I think
that d  as frame in is extremely important and
that's why I think the concept of
legalization is simply problematic
because it sends the wrong signal, such a
muted signal here, everything is good here, it's not
dangerous,
and I still think that's
extremely problematic because it
has an impact on who we are  serious
so i found the debate really exciting
and think leading this topic is
important, especially for young people in
the discussion about the legalization of
cannabis or, for some, the
controlled sale of cannabis,
you could see
that both debating graciously agreed
were about it it's illogical that
cannabis and alcohol should be
treated the same and i think one has also seen very
clearly that cannabis has long since
arrived in society
samples say yes too and
i found this consensus good yes i
think the debate has  super well heard
shown how irrational and arbitrary
the u  dealing with illegal
drug trafficking is for society and
how much suffering and avoidable damage
that simply means for those affected and all
people access of course
I can understand the arguments of the addiction
expert but
I personally think that
with legalization above all the
people who actually use cannabis
consumption must be
destigmatized the consequence
from my point of view must then
be to ensure that the dealer
is unemployed, that those who
sell illegally today no longer
simply have to pay their money, but that it can be made clear in
pharmacies and licensed shops
who sell what and how
I found the discussion very interesting. I was hoping for a few
more
insights into the modernization
projects in other countries. I think
you can learn from them yourself and
I would like to take a
closer look at that afterwards, because the
perspective from addiction rappi h  at
showed me again that there is
specialist expertise and problems that
had not been on the screen before and where
I think that
further discussion would definitely be
necessary we need
criminalization and above all better
prevention work and for me it is
clear  the federal election the issue of
cannabis has to be tackled because
probably with which you will
hardly soon maybe tomorrow maybe
yes and then you could avoid the big
mistakes that i was extremely
upset and am now
a judith
[music]